in the world of particle physics bigger
is better the bigger the detector you
can build the more you can see and the
bigger more powerful Collider you can
afford the more new particles you can
discover at the moment the world's most
powerful particle accelerator is the
Large Hadron Collider near Geneva
Switzerland
earlier this year scientists at the LHC
announced that they had found the Higgs
boson a new particle that is part of the
mechanism that allows all other
particles with mass but to really
understand the Higgs they want a new
Collider the international linear
collider the ILC will be 31 kilometres
long it will accelerate electrons and
anti electrons to near the speed of
light and create lots of Higgs bosons
for scientists to study but it will also
cost billions and with a global
financial crisis on most governments are
unwilling to pay Japan though might have
the political will to take on the
collider project at Keck Japan's high
energy physics laboratory scientists are
already busy testing parts of the new
collider
they are building superconducting
modules that will accelerate electrons
and anti electrons to high energies and
practicing focusing the particles and
too tightly packed bunches so that they
can smash into each other the work is
being done in collaboration with other
particle physics labs around the world
those nations could certainly help but
many scientists believe that only Japan
has the political will to actually build
the ILC at the moment both political
parties are willing to support the
project assuming they get enough help
from abroad
only time will tell whether this will be
the home of the next generation of
Collider